- I know guys, getting into
consulting can be very tough.
As a former ex-McKinsey
strategy consultant
today, I'm going to share
my best tips and strategies,
what you can do to get into consulting.
Hi, guys, how's it going?
Welcome to another coffee
break with Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich, and
welcome to my channel.
Today, I have something special for you,
because yesterday,
I did a webinar for the
Munich Student Society,
talking about how to
break into consulting.
I have the whole recording here for you,
and I trust that it has
been an excellent session
with lots of value and an
extensive Q&A at the end.
Below in the video description,
I'm leaving timestamps
for you to see all the individual
questions and sections.
So if there are only specific
elements that interest you
feel free to check the video description,
to directly jump to the parts
that interests you most.
Unfortunately, the start of the session,
the introduction got missing.
But basically the only
thing that you need to know
is that in the beginning
I introduced myself
and talked about my
educational background,
studying and Munich, London,
and the later the MBA
in France, Singapore.
And then also my professional background,
working as a consultant
later as a project lead at McKinsey
for a total of about six years
and now recently
transitioning into a CTO role
at a German fashion retailer.
I then talked about how,
from my perspective,
there are three main elements
when you think about how
you break into consulting.
First, what's the right experiences
that you need to get in.
Second, how you should set up
your written application materials,
and third the interview, how
you get the interview, right?
So the webinar is set up in a way that
are first given an impact
on these three topics.
And then I open it up for Q&A
with lots of student ask me questions.
As always, if it took any
value out of the video diary,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe to my channel
for weekly content on these topics.
As some of I also have
an Instagram channel
and my handle is Firm Learning.
On top of that, a few weeks ago,
I put together a consulting
interview preparation checklist
with my best tips and tricks,
what you can do to ace
your consulting interview.
If you're interested in that
you can download it for free
below in the video description,
I'm leaving a link there,
you just need to sign
up for the newsletter
and then you will get it to your inbox.
But now without further ado,
let's jump into the session
In my head,
I think about four different
types of internships
that you can do.
So corporate, consulting,
banking, or startup.
So from a business perspective for me,
these are the four categories,
and I'd believe that either of them
in theory works well.
I believe that what consultant firms,
of course like to see us,
you having done some kind of experience
in consulting before.
So, especially all I could target
is to get into McKinsey or BCG or Bain.
One of the MBB firms,
then probably having done some
internships at one of the,
maybe to two or one of the
smaller consulting firms,
maybe, Willem Baga or the Big
Four firms, PWC, Deloitte,
Ernst & Young, KPMG.
So these kind of a bit of smaller tiers
would be great internships to do,
to prepare yourself,
but you do not necessarily
need to do that.
Another category that is
often also very regarded is
internships in corporate firms.
And especially corporate firms
that our potential clients
of confiding firms, right?
So the big blue-chip companies,
especially in Munich,
you're lucky that there are so many,
no ducks, 30 companies in Munich,
Zeeman's and so on.
So these are companies that
are clients of consulting firms,
and consulting firms love that.
If you have intern that as well,
because this shows them that
you have already seen the
client side of the whole thing.
You have already have an understanding
how it looks like to be
at these kinds of firms,
the insight that these
people who work there.
So here as the well,
I would encourage you there as well.
And especially, again, if you're a Munich,
you have the best opportunities
because you just have all these
great household names just,
after behind your door,
it's just perfect.
And yes, just doing some
entrepreneurial things.
Other work achievements are
interesting here as well.
So if you have a little
entrepreneurial adventure,
maybe that you build up during
university with your friends,
this just shows that,
you're a bit of an entrepreneurial guy
who can show outside of the box,
who can think outside of the box.
And this is always very well
valued by the consulting firms.
Yes, consulting firms do
look at extracurriculars.
They do look at what you
have done left and right.
And I think the main rationale is that
for a consulting firm, what
they will expect from people is
not only that you do your
job well, on the job, right?
Not only that you do your job well,
being a consultant on the job,
but they will also expect you to help out
in your office to take up
some additional initiatives
in your office,
just to come up with
some great ideas as well.
But then you will do
on top of all your consulting work, right?
This will be expected
from you at some point
after the first year or so,
that you really take up
responsibility left and right,
doing some initiative projects,
helping out in your office
and that's effective.
Then you are able to
commit yourself socially
to some organizations that
you took the initiative
in the past, maybe politics or
some other force activities.
This just shows that you
are this type of person
that tumor just comes naturally
to do all these kinds of things.
And which is why
extracurricular experiences here
is important as well.
Then honors and awards.
So this is kind of the
first experience section.
One thing that I believe for
some people is very present
and for other people
that just do not have it
in their (mumbles) is scholarships.
So I think that scholarships
can be very helpful.
And for two things, right?
But first of course,
it helps you view your university degrees,
because you get money
and also a great network
if you are in these scholarship programs.
But it's also very good
signal to consulting firms
because the reason is that,
especially these BMBF
scholarship programs.
So if you don't know it,
the BMBF is Bundesministerium
für Bildung und Forschung.
So it's one of the big
ministerium in Germany,
one of the big government
departments in Germany.
And they have a scholarship program,
and they have i think, 12
or 13 different institutions
that give out the scholarships,
and probably the most well known is
the Studienstiftung des deutschen Volkes.
But then there are also
all kinds of scholarships.
Each political party has
one of the institution,
but then there's also the
Stiftung der deutschen Wirtschaft,
all the big religions have an institution
to which they give scholarships and so on.
So just the researchers, if
you're not familiar with that,
it's a very great opportunity.
And at least as far as I know,
you do not necessarily
need to be a German citizen
to get the money,
to do your own research here,
but it's a great opportunity
both to get funding.
And it is a really high regarded,
is highly seen by German employer's
because it shows them
that you were already able
to go through a pretty
advanced recruiting process
or a pretty advanced selection process
due to the sole scholarship thing,
because often they have been a
weekend off assessment center
or something like that,
that you need to go through
in order to get admitted to that.
So that really shows that
you're just up to the task, right?
And if they know invite you
to their interview process,
they have some confidence
that you were already able to pass
such a difficult process in the past.
And at McKinsey, at least
I'd say that 60, 70%
of the people probably
had one of these BMBF scholarships.
So it's pretty common.
Multiple people have it,
and I really encourage you to get it.
Also for me, it was a great experience.
Besides that, of course, Dean's
list, other academic honors,
try to collect this stuff as well.
And if you have any prices, of course,
this is always where we got it, right?
And this now of course
is then also the content
that then you should try
to get (mumbles) CV
because this is the stuff
that will make you interesting
for these big strategy consulting firms.
I'm sure you have lots
of questions on that.
So I am sure that later we
can also dive into that.
Let me just quickly go
over the presentation.
First of all, because now we are going
to the second element,
and this is now the written application,
and this pretty much consists
of two main documents,
namely the cover letter and the CV.
And the cover letter,
yeah, I know that many people
therese out about a lot,
oh, my dear,
what am I writing in
this cover letter, right?
And I believe the truth is that
there's is pretty much
seen as a hygiene factor.
And this means that,
having a lego, super great cover letter,
this is not what will
get you the job, right?
I mean, nobody is going to say, "Oh wow,
this guy, has just such
an amazing cover letter."
But of course, if you just mess up here,
if you do something that's unprofessional,
then this would just
be seen as a big no-go.
And then of course you,
so it's important just to get it right,
but don't believe that
this is now the most important thing
in this whole application.
And just kind of three suggestions
that I wanna give you,
three tips that I wanna give you
for the cover letter.
First, and this is now
here the third bullet,
make sure that you're very clearly,
probably in the first paragraph
of your cover letter,
that you communicate about three things.
First, when you want to start,
Second, in which office you want to start,
and third, what is the
specific role you want to in.
I mean, this for me,
I like the most important
point of information
that should be included
in the cover letter.
But I like to read lots of cover letters,
so friends also send me them,
but this is not included.
So make sure that this kind
of (mumbles) is included
just as a basic points of information
that should be in there.
And then also answer two things,
namely first,
why do you want to work in consulting?
What is your motivation?
And then finally,
like, why this firm?
I mean, what entices
you to work at McKinsey
or at BCG and so on.
And I know this can be difficult
because I mean, these firms,
they're are not that
difficult if you compare them,
but I think it is always something right
that you can draw on
is maybe if you've been
to a recruiting event,
and you really enjoyed the people there,
if you maybe know a
name of a recruiter also
that you work too.
And I mean, now you know me, right?
So if you want to apply to McKinsey,
you can also say that I talked to him.
And alumnus of the firm,
and you just really liked it, right?
So, I mean, just pointing out
some personal relationships
that you have
and just pointing out
that due to these personal relationships,
this is what really believes
that you like the people,
that you like the style,
that you like the culture,
this is just one of the
point that you could draw on
if you talk about
choosing a specific firm.
Few thoughts on the CV.
So here, I know that in Germany
many people like the two-page CV format,
I believe using two pages
for those of you ...
It's also okay
for sure,
do not use more than three pages.
I mean, this would be very bad.
Just try to stick to two.
And personally, I believe
that the one page format
is the way to go.
It's the best format.
It's just so amazing
just to have everything
on one piece of paper,
'cause of grasp
it's so much better.
I just love that.
And I'm sure that the HR departments
will have that as well.
So whenever possible, try to
get it down on one page CV.
And here you know,
I know many people that are saying,
Oh, Heinrich, I'm just such a great guy.
I just put so much stuff in my life.
No way I'm going to be able
to fit that on one page.
And I mean,
this is just complete BS, right?
I mean,
even if you are like a
CEO of a Duck's company
with 30 years of work experience,
you will always be able to
put it on a one page CV.
So just push yourself
out there to do that.
Regarding the CV,
I think the key sections
should be pretty much what we discussed
in the last page.
So Education, Work experience,
Extracurriculars, Honors
and awards
and then also other qualifications.
So these should be kind
of the main chapters
that you then have there
and that you then discuss.
And there's some more general remarks
that I see often made wrong in CV's
is regarding the highlighting
your contribution.
And often people use formulation such as,
we did something, our team
did this, we did something
in the CVs and the bullets that you write
on your CV,
make sure that you very much focused on
what you did,
what your impact was,
what your contribution was,
what did you achieve in a specific job
in the last internship?
What did you do?
What was your contribution?
And whenever possible,
also quantify that,
whenever possible, put a number to it,
to really make sure
that it's very tangible
what your achievements
of your impact actually.
And now, because I think now
I'm already over the time
of the 50 minutes that
I was supposed to talk
just a few quick thoughts on,
now the interview process,
so the third key building
block of getting in,
so usually there's three aspects of that
you have the CV interview,
you have the case interview
and you have an experience interview.
And sometimes this can be a bit mixed
depending on the firm.
Sometimes you will have an interview
where both the CV interview
and the case interview
or interview, where you have the case
and then an experienced interview,
but just a few brief point out
on these three interview types.
So just first this explanation,
what is a CV interview?
A CV interview is where you
basically go over the CV
with your interviewer, right?
So the interview,
you sit together with the interviewer
and then common questions are things like,
okay, please introduce yourself
or please guide me through your CV.
So these are some very basic questions
that you will find in almost
every interview process,
and just make sure
that you have a little
concise talk prepared, right?
So if somebody asks you,
okay, please give me a little
introduction about yourself
then this is now not the first time
you think about what to say,
but then you have like a little talk,
maybe five minutes or so prepared,
they really focus on the
most important stuff.
And you're able to give
a little presentation
about your CV, about your experiences
in five minutes or so
to really guide the interviewer through.
I think this is really
the most important thing,
that you not get lost
on one of the minor details in your life,
but are able to give a nice
and concise presentation
on your CV.
The second is the case interview.
And I know this is probably
what most people are afraid of
when they think about
interviewing with consulting.
I mean, this is where
people go crazy, right?
And really don't know what to do.
And here, just my main
recommendation would be,
yes, you should read
or you should practice
and yes, you should read all the material
that's all there in the Internet.
There are lots of great resources
where you can prepare for cases.
What I believe you should not do
is now to learn 50 frameworks
for all different subtypes of questions
that you could be asked.
I mean, you would just go
crazy if you do that, right?
So it's not about learning lots and lots
and lots of frameworks by heart,
that they need to repeat
in the interview process,
because this will also not
come across as natural.
This will not come across as reno.
You finding an innovative
solution to a problem
that you were provided
in the case interview,
but rather what I would
recommend you to do instead is,
prepare two or three basic frameworks
that you can use to
qualitatively structure problems,
structure things.
And if you just start learning,
start reading into these frameworks,
I'm sure that after some time
you can really distill
it to two or three ones
that will really helps you to
answer most of the questions.
Yes, learn these
frameworks, practice them,
but towards we are enough
normally to learn 50 frameworks
subdivided some parts.
And then the last thought
regarding the case interview.
What really helped me
when I prepare for my interviews
is that I paired, I put together with,
I think it was a
wonderful lady at the time
that interviewed also with BCG
and some other firms.
And we even met probably
once a week or so.
And we sat together
and for each session we
prepared a case for each other.
And then we always
interviewed the other person.
And this really worked out pretty well
because this day we both got practice.
We also got a bit of an experience
of being an interviewer,
because this is also an
interesting experience.
What do you look out for
them for the other candidate?
And then we gave us feedback.
So I would very much encourage you
because I believe the case
interviews are practice,
so the more you practice it the better.
And you should not only
practice by reading,
but you should really practice
by doing some actual more interviews.
This would be helpful to you.
This is what really will help you
then get in the actual interview.
And then finally the experience interview,
or some people also call
it the impact interview.
This is an interview type
where the interviewer
will ask you to talk
about specific situations,
specific instances that
you faced in your life,
what happened there and
how you reacted to that.
And here, common
questions are things like,
okay, please talk about a situation
where you had an interpersonal conflict
with somebody in your team
and how you solved it.
Or maybe you had a conflict
on a content matter, right?
So you disagreed with another person
what the best way is to move forward here,
and then how you solved it.
Or maybe a situation where
you really showed leadership,
where you really had an impact
that you're really proud of.
And what did you do?
How did you achieve that?
So questions like that.
And then where you are
supposed to come up with
tangible situations to talk about that,
where you really highlight
your leadership abilities,
your leadership experiences,
and how that might be
applicable in the future.
And here are my three main
recommendations would be first.
These questions, they're pretty easy.
Its usually not huge surprises,
so it's pretty easy for you to foresee
what types of questions will be asked,
then the executive questions
that I just told you
and some basic variations
of these kinds of things.
So you need to prepare yourself
in the way that when you
get asked these questions,
you should never put
yourself in a position
that then in the interview
on the spot,
you need to come up with a crazy story
that maybe happened to a
few years ago, whatever,
because this is not how it should go.
And set your shots at home.
Already think about situations like that.
You should have them very well prepared,
and you should already have an idea
for these kinds of main
oaks types of questions,
what situations you would talk about
so that you pretty much already know
what you're going to say.
And this is not something
that you should then
come up with on the spot
in these interviews.
And also just to warn you here,
this experience interview,
especially compared
with the case interview,
that's something that I feel like
many people significantly underestimates.
They've put lots of time and practice
on the case interview,
but they don't really spend a lot of time
at all on this experience interview part,
but at least what I know about
this experience interview
is often, at least as important
as the case interview.
So really do your favorite favor
to also get the preparation
down for that as well,
and just make sure that
you have all of this ready.
So this is just my little input.
Mayam, of course,
very happy to get your question.
- Well, first of all, Heinrich,
thanks so much for such
an insightful session
and no worries that you
went a little bit overtime,
actually that gave me some time to breathe
and now I'm back.
(laughs)
- All right.
- So, all the participants,
many of you submitted questions
during the registration process
and we have it right now.
So I will start with those questions.
Meanwhile, feel free to ask
questions live right now.
You can raise your hand
and then I will unmute you
and you can phrase your
question directly to Heinrich.
So to start with Heinrich,
you have a pretty interesting background
with degrees from several universities,
and in different fields.
So how was that overall
experience of education for you?
And how did it help you and shape you
with your career journey?
- Yap.
And so to be honest,
also talking about that a couple of times,
for me, probably the most formative time
was while I studied in Munich,
at the University of Munich at LMU.
I think this is really the time where,
from an academic
perspective I learned most.
And even though the later,
I was in London at LSE,
which is also considered
a good private university.
Later, also I did an MBA,
also of course,
very expensive program
where you can spend lots
and lots of money on that.
For me, really the most
formative experiences
is what I've done here in Munich at LMU.
And you guys have TUM.
So just kinda encourage you
just to take advantage of that experience
as much as possible
to engage in all the different,
student clubs, talk to other people,
there's also great and vibrant
startup scene in Munich.
This is really where I
just took away a lot from.
And on my specific
background after high school,
I just wanted to study business,
but I was always also
interested in philosophy.
But for me, it was also
a bit of an experiment
just to try to do a double degree.
Then in the University of Munich,
so I just signed up for
these two bachelor programs,
the philosophy program
and had a minor in history of art
when I studied in Munich,
and then also the business one.
So first of all,
some human experiment
to see how long I can do it,
but then in the end it
turned out quite well.
And then for me also,
great experience was in Munich, the CDTM,
the Center for Digital
Technology and Management,
they have an Honors degree.
It's open for both TUM students
and LMU students.
For me,
this was probably one of the
most formative experience
at Munich.
I can highly highly recommend that.
So, especially for those
who still at the beginning
of the bachelor,
or also at the beginning of the master,
you still have tie to do that.
Check out the CDTM program,
can really highly recommend it.
- Yeah, it's an excellent
program for sure.
And for the next question,
I will allow Adhil to
phrase this question.
So here you go, Adhil.
- [Adhil] Can you hear me?
- Yap.
- Yes
- [Adhil] I have a couple of questions,
but I will ask one question
and then if other participants
are done with the question,
then I can come back
to my other questions.
First of all, thank you very
much Mr. Heinrich for the talk,
it's very useful.
My question is keeping in mind
the increasing number
of consulting projects
that are right now getting
into the sector of technology.
What do you think are the
most valuable skill sets
within the consulting area?
- Yap.
I think this of course now depends a bit
on what role exactly in
consulting you wanna go for.
And probably also what
firm you're gonna go for.
So now assuming you would
go for McKinsey or BCG,
or anything like that.
Here the truth is that if you go in there,
if you are confined
to this more generalist confiding profile
is still what people will look for most.
And now of course,
if you wanted to project the technology,
if you wanna maybe be affiliated
with the digital practice,
then having some relevant experience
here of course would help.
And I think that this is not now specific.
It's not the case that
now you need to have
this super specific skillset
to now work in digital technology project
and strategy consulting firms.
And myself,
I mean, I'm not having super
focused digital profile
on my face.
And I did lots of digital
projects at McKinsey,
because you just learn over time
and you just pick it up.
But of course, it helps.
And probably specifically,
everything that's basically a hot password
at the moment will
somehow be helpful, right?
So if you do something with data science,
if you have some experience with AI,
but even things like online marketing,
this is something where
a lot of big companies
struggle with personalization at scale,
if I'm the big docs company
and I want to target my customers,
how do I leverage my data to do that?
How do I make sure that
everybody gets the right ad
for the things that they really need?
Big data projects, hardware,
but also the network design system design.
How do I now improve the system landscape
in the company?
How do I integrate the
legacy systems and so on?
So these are all things that are relevant
from the strategy,
concise and perspective,
and you will be able to leverage that.
There's no one specific
skill that you need to have.
I think you can role
on all these different
types of backgrounds
and now, of course,
if you're more interested in
IT consultant type of role,
I don't know if you
wanna work at Accenture,
there in the technology arm or something,
then it might get more
specific-based on the road
that you're interested in.
So when I was a student,
I did an internship for
empathetic Accenture,
and I was working on an
SAP implementation project.
And there was very super specific
on business intelligence,
BI, being able to build these all up cubes
and all this stuff around that, right?
So and this gets more tailored,
more relevant to the specific job,
but in general, yes,
(mumbles) tax codes,
all they regarded,
it would probably not be
now the super deal breaker,
so I mean, as a consultant,
the things that they usually struggle for
is more generalist type of skillset,
but then having a strong tech focus
on one or two very relevant skills
would kind of be the cherry on top,
that then can really help you to get in.
- [Adhil] Thank you.
- And next is Christopher
- [Christopher] Okay, can you hear me?
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- [Christopher] Okay, nice, thank you.
First of all, thank you
for the short overview.
I really liked insights.
My question will be,
I'm currently in the second semester
of my bachelor's degree,
and I'm also aiming to
start a double degrees
from this winter semester.
- Okay
- [Christopher] Like on
the homepage for example
of McKinsey, they usually write
you can apply for internship
from your third semester on.
Is there a certain point,
well, like a point in time in your studies
that you would recommend an internship?
Or let's say, like at this point in time
it makes actually sense
to start an internship
because you can actually
work on some projects
(audio glitch) enough knowledge.
- Yeah.
So here my recommendation would be,
or what you need to
understand to put it this way.
What I need to understand is that first,
if you apply and then you don't get in,
usually you get a block
of at least one year,
sometimes even one and a half years
before you can apply again.
So if you basically
apply after your second
or third semester,
and then you don't get in,
then usually you cannot just
apply again one semester later.
And then these, for my knowledge,
this is not only the case for McKinsey,
but for most of the other
consulting firms as well.
So you probably not apply
if you feel like you don't
have a realistic chance
at the moment,
because this will really hurt you,
then, because then you will not be able
to apply later again.
This is the first
consideration to have in mind.
And then the second thing is that,
if they hire an intern,
especially at the MBB consulting
firm, from McKinsey, BCG,
and so on,
they will put you
on an extra project team.
So you will be at least
in like 99% of the cases
you would work at the client
on an actual engagement,
you will be in meetings
with clients alone,
the team will depend on you.
And for these reasons they will have,
let's say kind of some minimum stand ups
that they will want you
to get or to achieve,
if they hire you for an internship.
So, it's not the case
that they basically have kind
of staggered requirement list
that they think, okay,
if somebody is only in the
second semester of the bachelor
then this is the level he needs to be at.
If he is at the fourth
semester of the bachelor
then this is the level
he it needs to be at.
Or in the first master semester
then I expect more.
But pretty much the standard
of getting hired as an intern,
it's pretty much the same,
doesn't matter if you're on
your bachelor or your master.
So, and for these reasons,
yes, you can do an
internship during a bachelor.
Also, I did mine internship
after my fifth semester
of my bachelor,
and that would be possible.
I would also be a bit careful
because if you are still
early in your studies,
probably you're also still a bit younger,
maybe a bit less mature,
you'll also, the perception of you
might also be even more junior
than maybe a year or two years from now.
So just be a bit realistic
about where you currently stand
with your skill set,
with your personality,
whether you would really be able to sit
in front of senior clients
or whether maybe it makes sense
to wait another year or so,
to get a bit more experienced,
maybe have done another internship,
until then you're really ready to apply.
- Thanks, Heinrich.
I will take one question
from the questions
that were submitted before.
So the participant asks,
"is there a more focus on
any particular industry
in German consulting than others?"
- Yes.
So in general you need to
understand that actually Germany
is a country
that likes consulting a lot.
So for the German market,
for the confiding firms
is one of the most important
markets in the whole world,
and to in the U.S.
So Lisa McKinsey wants of the case of
they have split the U.S.
and like three main offices.
And so let me just,
I don't want to talk
about specific numbers,
but let's just say that Germany is like an
insanely important market.
And even if you control for
the size of the economy,
so for the GDP or whatever,
zero consulting services play,
even then play still a
larger role with many other
compared to many other countries.
So for whatever reason,
German companies like consultant,
those are just effect.
And what this means is that
if you're here in Germany,
if you work in Germany,
probably you are also in
terms of career perspective
of the chances of making
it to partner and so on,
probably are better than in
other countries like U.K.
or France or so on,
not only because the size
of the economy is larger,
therefore, more opportunities,
but also many, many
industries are more inclined
to work the consultant.
But then yes,
there are some differences
among industries.
I would say that especially
if you work for a large
company like McKinsey,
you wouldn't have opportunity
to work in every industry.
I mean, there's pretty much no
industry that we do not serve
or that we didn't serve.
So it's not that,
if you sign up with a company
such as McKinsey does,
this one industry where
you will not work for sure.
But the truth is also
that in some industries
there are just significantly
less opportunities
than in other industries.
And for instance,
I don't know, for instance, retail.
I mean, yes, there are studies, product
and retail all the time.
And I did also pretty of
retail projects during my time.
But whenever you look at a
retail staffing newsletter,
so maybe we have like
regular staffing newsletter
sent out all the people.
So you know what the
current opportunities are,
feel free from your project.
And if you, then we're looking at
a retail newsletter,
often, they're like three, four, five, six
new things going on at
a given point in time.
And if you look at for instance,
advanced industries, automotive,
these more tech oriented industries,
you have lots of pages of opportunities
that you could start,
so just to give you a bit
of a central perspective.
So there are some differences
and specifically banking is big.
Automotive is big,
advanced industries is big,
farmer can be very big.
So these industries are common.
Now that bigger things like retail,
consumer goods,
also the digital thing.
So companies like Google,
Facebook and so on.
I mean, it doesn't want to say
that there are no opportunities
at all with these companies,
but they're not better fiend to consulting
than these more old-school
German tech companies I'd say.
- We have another question
that goes in line with
this one in our Q&A.
So the participant asks
that would you recommend
to get into in-house
consulting of the industries
that you have mentioned?
And is it possible to
have a transition from
in-house consulting in this
industries to the Big Four
or big three, let's say?
- Yeah.
So it depends on your goal I'd say.
So I think the main reason why
people do in all consulting
is because they believe
it's pretty much comparable
to a trainee program I'd say.
So you started in-house consulting firm,
and then you have these
different projects,
and for that, you have exposure
to different departments,
you get to know different people,
and then you build a
network in that company
and this will enable you to
hopefully (mumbles) the idea
to then do a nice transition
to a good senior role.
And I believe this is a valid rationale,
it kind of work.
And of course, then the
reputation of the investment firms
differ, but from a firms,
so obviously Zeeman's
has a very renowned thing
with Zeeman's management consultants.
And some other programs are
probably not that established,
but if this is your goal,
then this is, I'd say viable.
I mean, I didn't do that first-hand,
but it is from what I've
seen also in some companies,
I've worked together with these
and I was consulting people.
What I believe is not a good idea
is to start in an
in-house consulting firm,
just to then, later to
do the switch to MBB
or to Big Four.
At least from McKinsey,
I think about,
I cannot imagine a senior guy
who transitioned from
in-house consulting firm.
This is not to say that it's impossible,
but also just in terms of the story,
I just feel like it
doesn't make much sense.
I mean, if you want to do consulting,
then why wouldn't you directly start
with the big consulting firms.
And if you want to corporate
then rather start in a corporate role.
But I mean, I think you need
to be very (audio glitch)
you can tell a convincing story here,
like what your rationale
should be about (mumbles).
Probably not the best idea.
It's not impossible,
but that wouldn't necessarily recommend.
- Great.
Alberto, you are next.
- [Alberto] Hello, can you hear me?
- Yes.
- [Alberto] Hi, everyone.
And thank you for the sessions.
It's a really helpful and informative,
so really appreciate it.
My question is,
so, I'm currently in my
second-last semester at TUM,
for my master's degree in management.
And I was thinking about
applying to the Big Three
in their Italian offices,
'cause that's where I'm from.
Therefore I wanted to ask you,
if to your knowledge,
if there are any variations
or differences in the recruiting process,
depending on where the office is located.
And where could you find information
on how to account for
that and prepare for that.
And also how much do McKinsey,
BCG and Bain value
international experiences.
And if that's actually
something that can make a difference,
or you should just focus on other things.
So yeah.
Thank you.
- Yeah, of course.
So first, I mean, yes,
there can be some differences
regarding the application process.
Usually, at least with the larger firms
these differences are
not huge, but they exist.
Just to give you an example,
when I started at McKinsey
there still was something that was called
the PSP problem solving tests.
It was pretty much,
I think somebody has,
maybe somebody can put himself on mute
because I'm hearing myself double.
Some red echo.
So there was something like the PST,
the problem solving tests,
and this was kind of a written test
where you needed to answer
little-like math problems.
So you were really sitting
there in the office
when you conducted the interviews,
and then they had like
a little written test.
And I think in Germany at McKinsey's,
now they don't have it anymore,
but in some other countries
I think they still do.
And then another thing that
is now currently tested
at McKinsey, as far as I know,
it's kind of an online game that they use.
I believe they use it
also in the very first twinning process.
So this is something that
candidates needs to do at home.
And it's kind of a little game,
it's about equal systems
where they need to make
sure that all the ecosystems
are imbalanced or something.
There's other thing you can also
on the McKinsey career page,
you can find some basic
information on that.
But I believe this is not
there in every country yet,
because they're just slowly testing it
and then rolling it out to one of them.
I'm not a hundred percent sure
whether the moment it's
already live in Germany or not.
I mean, to find out,
you should just check the
career page of the local office.
So if you go to a McKinsey,
like the German McKinsey
page and they are on kiryl,
you will find the basic information
on how it's run in Germany.
And I trust the same thing will be true
if you then go on the Italian page.
So check out your local recruiting page,
and then there will be
the key information,
and then at least after you apply it,
and then if you get
invited to an interview
then usually you will also get
lots of additional
information from the HR team.
The whole executive
interviews will be random
and what would be expected from you.
So of course,
we get that information
then and beforehand.
And regarding the
international experience.
So I think what's usually
not that valued is,
frankly is languages.
So not having language skills
and lots and lots of different languages
is usually not considered
super important or whatever.
I think what's of course
important is English.
So that you have to go
through an English case.
And of course,
what many consulting firms
want is language skills
in the local office.
So, if you want to apply for German role,
especially for client facing role,
then yes,
people will expect from you
not necessarily to be fluent,
but at least to have kind of
business level German skills.
And the same as to also
for other countries
for their respective language.
But usually it's not a huge factor
on whether you can speak
other languages as well.
Of course, though it doesn't hurt,
and it will enable you
potentially also to do projects
in that country,
if you want to go there
then during your engagement.
Regarding, other experience
such as being abroad
or something like that,
having spent a semester
abroad, internship abroad,
I think, yes, this is valued.
So again, it's more like a hygiene factor,
in the sense that I believe
if people kind of expect you to have it.
So I believe if you have it,
it's not like a huge PLASP.
People will not be like,
wow, this guy's so great
because he was abroad,
but it's more like the other way round.
If you don't have it,
then people will rather
notice it in a negative way.
And this is not to say
that your chances are zero.
If you have never worked abroad,
a few have never done a semester abroad,
so it's still possible to get in,
but this will be seen
as something negative.
And the rationale, here again is just,
you live up frequently with
people from other countries.
Also, me working at McKinsey,
probably 50% of my studies were abroad,
but not in Germany.
So you will also be staff
potentially on studies
outside of Germany
or outside of the country.
And there, you can just give
the people a bit of confidence
that you will handle the situation well
if you already show some
international experience.
- Thank you, Heinrich.
- Sure.
I just realized we are approaching
towards the end of the session
and there are still a
lot of hands that are--
- We can go a bit over time if you want.
I mean, I'm flexible.
- That's great.
And I would try to integrate
as many as questions possible.
- Mm-hmm.
- So next question is
are salaries is higher
in consulting invest
in South Germany than in East Germany.
- So, I mean, yeah
there might be differences
not far but (mumbles)
but my general take on that is,
or maybe just to start even
on the international level.
So even within one company at BCG
or McKinsey or whatever, yes,
salaries will be different
country-by-country.
So it will be adopted to the
local competitive situation
to the local living costs and so on.
And actually Germany
has pretty good salaries
actually I'd say,
compared to other countries
in consulting in general.
This is also true for banking.
So if you go to U.K. or something,
I mean, especially then
if you're in London,
especially given that
the other living costs
are so much higher,
I believe the salaries in
Germany are really attractive
and very interesting.
Now within Germany,
at least with the big
firms like BCG, McKinsey,
also the Big Four,
you should usually expect
that they will not
differentiate with in Germany.
And the reason also is
that at least at McKinsey,
you can pretty much freely
change offices between Germany.
So I started actually
in the Berlin office,
and then I transitioned to
the Munich office later,
just due to private reasons
because my wife moved there.
So for these reasons
in general, no,
they will not differentiate
between Eastern
and Western Germany,
though of course,
now if you're looking into
smaller consulting firms,
smaller boutiques or whatever,
then maybe,
I mean, in general, of course,
it's true that in general
the average salaries
in the East are lower than in the West.
- I see.
I'll take another participant question
from the Q&A section.
And the question is,
it's no secret that you
need really good grades
to get into consulting.
Do you think it's problematic
or even a no-go if you
didn't finish your degree
within the regular time period,
and you took one or two semester longer?
- No, I don't think so.
I mean, of course,
it's good to then have
some kind of rationale,
but I mean, it's always possible
to come up with some more
or less convincing reason
why you did that.
I mean, I'm sure you have a reason,
otherwise you would have done it faster,
so maybe you've been abroad
or maybe you did some cool internships,
maybe you did something
else from paradigms
that really took your time.
And then I do not think
that this is a huge issue.
Of course, then if it took longer
and then also your
grades are not that good
and so on.
I mean, then this can add
up to maybe an impression,
which is not that great.
Of course, it's helpful
to have competed it
in the regular time.
But this in most cases should
not be a huge tiebreaker
- Okay, so there's a question
from Jan in the chatbox,
and also a couple of participants
during registration
submitted the same question,
that they have a couple
of years of experience
raging from two to five years.
And they have been working
on this for quite some time,
like getting an internship
into in-house consulting
or a Big Four consulting.
And all the tips that you
provided in the session,
in the beginning
they have been working on it,
on CV and cover letter
and all those stuffs,
and still things are not really working.
So, what would you advise to such people?
- Okay, I mean, you
would really need to look
into the specifics.
So, I mean,
it might be the case
that there's a problem
with your documents.
So here you should really
make sure that these are okay.
So, from a former
perspective it's all there.
And so I would recommend
that you really work
with some people whom you trust,
would be able to (mumbles) of that
to then get you some feedback.
And actually, if you're
interested in that,
on my YouTube channel,
I have recently made a video about CVs,
where I actually reveal
real examples of CVs
of other people.
And there are also lots of tips
on how to put specific things.
So if are just interested in that
check out this video
on my YouTube channel.
But just make sure that
your material is there.
And then if you still get not invited,
then unfortunately,
the profile just doesn't seem to meet
the criteria, unfortunately.
And here of course, then
I would also recommend you
with probably the only shot that you have.
There's just a try to network, right?
So try to go maybe to career first,
to some HR people,
maybe then also if you
have the opportunity
to talk to one person face-to-face,
and maybe you can just find another guy
who works at the firm
who does really can get
you some extra feedback on
your profile.
Maybe also how you frame certain things.
Then maybe you get a shot often,
or at least getting
invited to the interview,
because I think this was
also one of the questions.
Just to quickly touch on that.
The question is,
does networking help?
Can you get into the firm?
Just because you have,
Germany, you say vitamin B,
so you have relationships
with food to some people.
And usually for most companies
you can get to the interview by that.
So if you now the right people,
and if they're really like you,
and if you find a partner
who really believes you are a great guy,
he can push you to get an interview.
But then from the interview,
you are on yourself.
I mean, in the interview you
will then be assessed by a team
and then nobody will sabotage
the whole recruiting process for you,
just to get you through.
And even if a partner would do that,
that would be, probably wouldn't work.
And we also support that first reputation.
So yes, it can help you.
Networking can help you
to get an interview,
but then from the interview
you are on yourself.
So if for whatever reason
your profile just isn't there,
then really try to talk to these people,
try to convince them,
but then of course, it will be difficult.
But yeah, but this isn't
the chance you have.
- Thanks.
Now Lorena asks,
what was your struggle while
getting into consulting?
If you could share a
couple of thoughts on that.
And in line with it,
I will quickly face next question as well.
If you could also share your experiences
of two excellent projects
that you did in consulting
and two most challenging projects
that you did in consulting.
(laughs)
Okay, so, my challenges, I mean,
to be honest, I was kind of lucky
because I was in a bachelor
and I just wanted,
I already did a couple of internships
and I just wanted now to
do a consulting internship.
And then I just applied
to a couple of firms
and actually then the McKinsey one
was one of the earlier interviews.
And I think I was well prepared.
I did lots of mock case studies.
I did a couple of other interviews before,
and then added the McKinsey one.
And then I got in for the internship,
and then actually also
canceled the other ones,
because for whatever reason I always,
McKinsey was kind of my dream from then,
to work at that time.
And then I just signed up there
and then what's of course possible
is once you do the internship,
then if you perform well,
then you can get an offer to
work with the firm afterwards.
And then actually,
because my master was only one year.
So sometimes it's kind of the time limit
that you need to,
then decide to join after
a certain amount of time.
But one year usually is fine.
For then I was able to
basically start my master,
already with the offer of then
joining McKinsey afterwards.
It was of course, a super
comfortable position.
So I guess I just was lucky.
And for these reasons I
didn't have a huge struggle
to be honest.
But then of course, in consulting,
not with the two best
and two worst projects,
then you will struggle a lot on the job.
Everybody would have bad projects
and this can be super tiresome
just to share two stories.
One thing was,
or just to (mumbles),
just to talk about one thing here,
I think in the end,
what it comes down to,
to whether you enjoy a project or not,
it's not so much on the content.
It's not so much on the topic,
but even though of course, some topics,
some projects can be more
interesting than other, no doubt,
but what I believe,
what most people feel like
then also who I've talked to,
some other colleagues,
the defining factor is your team,
and your clients.
The team that you work with,
probably number one,
and then the clients who
work with number two.
And I was once in a tough situation
where I didn't get along way
with the team I work with,
and also didn't got
along way with the client
or with the main clients
that I was responsible for.
And this really was a difficult situation,
because after some time,
you need to,
every Monday morning you fly there,
then you get into the team room,
and then there's the weird
atmosphere in the team room,
then you talk to the clients,
then a weird atmosphere with the clients.
And then, also then on top of that,
the stress of working late every day
of then talking to the partners
who are unhappy and so on.
I mean, this is really an experience
that was just,
its so tiresome
Somebody crushes you so much
of the time psychologically,
but here I think the good
part is in consulting.
And I think everybody,
if you're work in consulting
at some point in time,
you would have an experience like that,
but everybody will have one
or two bad projects you can talk about.
But the good thing is,
and I think this is really a
contrast compared to industry,
after two, three, four, five months,
once a project is over,
the cards are usually mixed again,
so you can work together
with new colleagues,
you can work with a new company
and you can basically start
again from a fresh slate.
Then of course, over time,
you really get to know the people
you really enjoyed working with,
the one partner you really enjoyed.
The project leads really laughed,
was really a great guy.
And then you can stick
together with these people
and then try to work more
and more with these people.
And then this is how you create
the soul kind of set of
people who support each other.
And then there's just a great experience.
If you contrast that with corporate,
you start in a team in corporate,
you have these teammates,
you have this one boss,
you're one team that you will work with.
And then usually for the
next three, four, five years,
this would be your family.
And you can either be lucky,
and it works out really well.
Or for whatever reason,
you can be really unlucky
and you just really don't get along
with these people at all.
And then basically your only option
is to switch jobs.
I mean, you will never hear that.
I mean, if you're really
some point in the position,
then at some point you just need to leave.
I mean, this is just about consulting
this to lots of flexibility,
just to talk about a
positive example is red.
This is when you have all
these things come together.
So it was
just one of my recent ones,
it was an automotive company,
an automotive supplier.
And the topic itself was interesting,
but not super exciting.
But we really got along with
the clients really well.
There were also some nice junior people.
Then on the evening,
sometimes we would go out with them,
on the weekends we would ...
Because I was living in
the same city with them
we would meet,
we would have some drinks.
The team was super cool.
We all got along super well,
the product wasn't going well,
everybody was helping.
Everybody was just having a good time.
The impact wasn't bad,
or worked up really great.
With this of course, also always cool.
If you can see that what you're doing
really impacts the
company in a positive way,
and you're really helping.
And if all of this comes together,
then it just so great.
And then you also don't mind
anymore if you work late
or if you work until late in the evening
or something like that.
This is really when you
love doing your job,
and you really love coming
into the office every day.
And the truth is such, will
not be like that every day.
But you will also come
across these products,
and they're just amazing.
And then over time
you could really choose more and more,
the people you wanna work with.
And this is just,
I believe the magic of
working in consulting.
- Yeah, quite exciting, I would say.
And the good and bad
both things are that it will end.
I mean,
(laughs)
- Exactly.
- So I'll take the next question from Rue.
He asks what is the
percentage of non-Germans
and non-Europeans in McKinsey?
And I think in general
how much focus is there in German seen
in consulting about international people?
I will combine it with another
question about the language.
So the participant asks that
my Germany is at intermediate level
and I'm working on it.
But meanwhile, I do want
to get into consulting.
What would you advise me on this stage?
- Well, first of all,
the quarters of Germans and so on.
And of course, if you look at the company
on a global level,
then I'd say it's representative
of the geographies
that you are based on.
The U.S. office, they of course,
most of the people will be from the U.S.
and Germany, most people
will be from Germany and Asia
and specific countries.
The most people would be
from the local geographies.
So kind of on a global level
I'd say it's very much mixed.
Of course, in the German,
also the majority of
the people maybe German
and the main reason for that is that
you will need to be fluent in Germany
or at least to kind of
in an advanced level,
as a German speak out to work
in the German office of consulting firms.
And again, now if you
maybe working IT consulting
where maybe you're also not
that client facing and so on,
there might be some differences,
but at least for the
big MBB consulting firms
from McKinsey, BCG, Bain or so
you can assume that then yes,
you will need to speak the language.
So what can you do
if you do not have that
level of proficiency
in the German language,
but you wanna still work in Germany?
I mean, frankly, I believe
the only thing, at least
again, if you now look at
the MBB consulting firms,
the only roles that you
might be then open for
are more kind of the back office role,
the analytics teams,
the support teams,
and there can be some exciting
opportunities as well,
so especially if you have some IT skills,
there are always statistics teams like,
data modeling, data science teams
that then support the consultants
from the background.
And then yes, maybe you
would also then a few days
join the team on the ground of the client
to help them every bit (mumbles)
together with somebody.
And then you just kind of
support them in these ways.
There then also research teams,
so McKinsey (mumbles) RNI
research and information.
So, whenever a consultant
needs to collect information
from reports or whatever,
then there are these research guys,
they can then draw on
to then conduct these analysis for them.
But the truth, also see us,
even though I'd say these
are interesting jobs
and they're also very fairly compensated,
it's not what you are envisioning
if you work in consulting.
It's not really the life of
the client facing or tightened,
and also,
in the firm.
So even though this is
kind of a constant topic,
I'd say the culture
even though people try lots
to now create a class system in the firm,
but you man, people are above the other
or something like that.
That's just the fact that,
there's one level with the
client facing consultants.
And then there's the other
level with all the rest,
all the people supporting them.
And I think people do a very good job
of trying to not make
these people feel bad
and trying to encourage them,
and to have a great and
inclusive firm environment.
And I believe in companies like McKinsey,
this works really well.
But I would ask myself,
but this is really the experience
that you want to have,
or whether there are maybe
some other opportunities
that maybe suit your profile,
suit your goals to be better.
Because also the truth is by,
it does happen.
Sometimes people make the switch.
So I know also a couple
of people who did that
from these more back office research roads
into then the client
facing consulting role.
So it's not impossible,
but I'd say it's very rare,
and rather than usually.
So this is not something
you should count on
of then doing the switch.
It's just very uncommon.
There are some examples,
but it's just very uncommon
and you should bid your career
based on the idea.
Then after some years you
just do the transition.
So this is not something you can count on.
- Thanks.
Just checking the questions.
Well, very quick note.
I mean, we are almost,
we're already over the time.
Still I will try to
incorporate all the questions.
- Sure.
I think I will take one from
the pre-submitted questions
and that is,
are you part of McKinsey alumni network?
And could you share what role
does it play after the exit?
- Yes, I'm part of the alumni network,
and I think everybody
has to leave the farm
in good standing.
So yes,
frankly, I haven't used it that much yet
because I also directly got a new job.
I believe that's kind of a panto
where you then can get in
touch with other alumni,
and then there are also regular events
that on the alumni meet.
So frankly, I haven't
really made use of that.
So I believe it can be helpful.
It's probably not now,
a life changing experience
of being in this.
Alumni network,
but of course, there are many alumni
now who work in inferential roads
around the world and lots of companies,
and are reaching out to them
via either we are the official network
or via LinkedIn,
or some other ways.
I believe of course, it's
helpful for you in the long-run.
But I trust,
this is similar with
other big firms as well.
- You're also targeted this
during earlier questions
that it's a very high performing job
and it takes a lot of time.
So however, it also depends
on country-to-country
and office-to-office,
the culture and working hours.
So how is it exactly in Germany?
- Yeah, I mean, there are lots
of stereotypes around that.
I mean, the stereotype
is that the German office
is one of the worst offices
in terms of work-life balance--
- Germany love to work.
(laughs)
- That's to work,
probably only toped
in the negative sense
by the Italian office.
So the Italian office is
considered even worse,
and also the Japan office
is considered very bad.
I mean, these are probably
like the top three.
And then on the other side,
people who are considered
to be very chilled
is all the Nordics,
so if you work in the Nordics,
this is considered very laid back,
but also the Dutch office, for instance,
this is to be considered quite chill.
And then the rest is
somewhere in the middle.
I mean, probably in terms of direction,
this is true.
But again, it differs a
lot project-by-project
and also the people that you work with.
Some projects just will
make you work longer
than other projects just
because how the setup is,
just how the requirements are.
And they're also just some teams,
some project leads who are more sensitive
to work-life balance than others.
And here again,
this is all a bit also something
that you will learn over time
to kind of find the people
that you like to work with.
And then maybe these
can also be the people,
do not push you until
after midnight every night.
Because it just can be
super tired afterward.
So, but yes,
the truth is that you
will work much longer
than many other jobs.
The positive side of that,
and this is also true
for the German office,
at least at McKinsey what I experienced
is that the weekends
are very well respected.
And this is I believe a big difference too
for instance banking.
So if you work in
Frankfurt, in the MesseTurm
with Goldman Sachs or whatever
you can expect to be in
the office every Saturday,
every Sunday,
weekends every week.
This is not the case with
the big consulting firms.
So I mean, yes,
there's really a hard business need.
And it's now very, very urgent,
then yes, you will be asked
to work on the weekend.
And then this would be
also expected from you,
for probably for me this happens
five, six, seven times or so
in the years I've been at McKinsey.
So it does happen,
but not super frequently.
And so we can solve very well respected
and I believe it this is a big (mumbles).
- Great.
Adhil is still raising hands.
So I will allow him to talk.
- Sure.
- Adhil, here you go.
- [Adhil] My question is,
does an MBA add any value to somebody
who wants to enter consulting?
And my second question is,
it possible to transition from consulting
to investment banking
after getting three to
four years of experience
in consulting?
- So the first question,
I mean, yes, an MBA (mumbles)
or no, let's put it differently.
I'd say consulting firms
hire a lot of MBAs.
This is effect,
especially if did an MBA
at one of the big well
respective programs,
you have a good chance of them
getting hired by consulting.
I mean, I did the incite MBA in France,
and then also on the Singapore compost.
And this is one of the MBA programs
that is very close to consulting firms.
So a lot of people then join consulting.
Also a lot of people
with other backgrounds
before with industry background,
corporate backgrounds
later joined MBB consulting firms.
So this is for sure a
path that you can take.
But this is not to say
that you need to have an
MBA to get into consulting,
especially in Germany,
I'd say that MBAs are still
not that popular.
So for instance,
doing a PhD in Germany
is much more popular
than doing an MBA.
And it's not at all a must have criteria
to condition into the consulting role.
So of course, now it
depends on your profile.
For some profiles, it can really help,
maybe you have a more
specific corporate role,
kind of more technical role
of some years of experience
in a big corporate or something.
Then from that, maybe it can be a bit hard
to not directly position into
strategy consulting firm.
And then an MBA can really help you
to make it more interesting to employers,
to maybe also broaden
all your horizon a bit.
And then for these kinds of profiles
that can be very helpful to have an MBA.
Now you need to remind
me of the second part
of the question again.
- Second part of the question
was I think, can you transition
into investment banking
from consulting after?
- Yeah.
So yes, this is possible.
And I've also seen,
I mean, I know of
different people who did.
Here, of course, (mumbles)
that then during your consulting time,
you did relevant projects.
So for instance, you
did lots of udiligences
you worked maybe close
to M&A things and so on,
but of course you need to realize
that your udiligences
probably are the worst projects out there
in terms of work life balance.
So, because the diligence is off
not only two weeks,
three weeks, four weeks,
it's a very short amount of time.
You work together with
lots of other professionals
of private equity and so on.
And I mean, I knew one
guy who was just crazy.
I mean, he was literally crazy,
and he did one due
diligence after each other
and like for a year or two years or so.
I mean, if this is what you want to do,
then, feel free,
but you just need to realize
that this is the probably
the type of stuff
that investment firms,
investment banking firms
would be interested in,
but this is the stuff that really is one
of the toughest stuff to do.
And of course that's also middle way.
And maybe you do that occasionally,
and then you do that
for two or three weeks
and then you go do more normal projects
and then you do the diligence this again.
And of course, also
some other project work
in the corporate finance road and so on
where maybe it's not like the diligence
all the time can also
be interesting to banks,
but just be aware that
probably then you need
to make sure that you really also go into
that direction a bit in consulting,
because I believe if you just
did digitalization projects
for marketing and say it's not
coinciding with the new one,
and then you want to transition
into an investment bank,
probably that's going
to be a bit difficult.
- Great.
Well, I think with this,
we are done with most of the questions
and we will end the session over here.
- Cool
Thank you so much once again,
all the participants and have
a huge thank you to Heinrich.
I will quickly launch a survey,
please let us know.
How did you how did you like the session
and you all know me,
you all have my details, contact details.
So do, let me know if you
want more such sessions
and very quickly
apologies to be nervous in the beginning.
I mean, you have seen
my sessions with AEs.
This won't happen again.
And Heinrich thanks so much for coming,
(mumbles) little bit more
(laughing)
- Thank you, don't worry.
Don't worry again.
Thank you guys
- Again, all of you who want
to get in touch with Heinrich,
Heinrich has a YouTube channel
and he's also there on Instagram
with the handle name, Firm Learning.
He, shares excellent YouTube
videos on the same topic.
Feel free to follow him,
feel free to reach out to him,
and have a great weekend.
Thank you so much, guys.
- Thank you guys and enjoy the
weekend all the best to you.
So that's it
for those of you who
watched until the very end.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
And if you still have any questions
that you also want to answer,
just leave a comment below
in the comment section
and I'll do my very best
to answer every single one.
Again, please hit the like button,
please subscribe to see even more from me
and also turn on the notification
there to get informed
whenever I release a new video.
Good weekend to all of you.
This has been Heinrich from
Firm Learning until next week.